Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dans ScienceClic,
la superposition quantique.
Dans l'univers, tous les objets, sont caractérisés
par un ensemble de grandeurs bien définies,
comme la position, la vitesse, ou encore la
masse. Pour chacune de ces grandeurs, on peut
effectuer une mesure, et ainsi en déduire
une valeur.
Par exemple, on peut peser une pomme à l'aide
d'une balance, et de la sorte mesurer sa masse.
On pourra alors attribuer une valeur bien
définie à la masse de cette pomme.
A notre échelle cependant, même si l'on
n'a pas encore pesé la pomme, celle-ci a
déjà une masse bien définie. Le fait de
peser la pomme va seulement nous révéler
la valeur de cette masse.
Ainsi l'état de la pomme, c'est à dire l'ensemble
de toutes les valeurs que l'on peut mesurer,
comme sa masse, sa position, ou sa vitesse,
reste inchangé que l'on aie effectué la
mesure ou non.
Cependant si l'on s'intéresse à des échelles
de plus en plus petites, jusqu'à atteindre
le monde des atomes, des phénomènes étranges
commencent à apparaître, et cette description
du monde n'est plus valable.
Si l'on s'intéresse à la position d'une
particule, cette particule pourrait par exemple
se trouver dans un état A, où sa position
serait située en un point A, elle pourrait
également se trouver dans un état B, où
sa position serait située en un point B,
mais la particule pourrait également se trouver
dans un état plus complexe, qu'on appelle
état superposé, et qui serait formé
à partir des états A et B.
Dans cet état superposé, A et B pourraient
intervenir dans des proportions égales, mais
la particule pourrait également se trouver
dans un état superposé où A intervient
davantage que B, ou encore dans un état superposé
où A intervient beaucoup moins que B.
Lorsqu'elle se trouve dans cet état superposé,
la particule ne se situe alors ni en A, ni
en B, et elle ne se situe pas non plus aux
deux endroits en même temps. En réalité,
la particule n'a tout simplement pas de position,
car la notion même de position n'a plus aucun
sens à l'échelle quantique.
Si maintenant on essaie d'observer cette particule,
alors un phénomène étrange se produit.
Au moment de la mesure, la particule va changer
d'état. Comme elle se trouvait dans une superposition
des états A et B, la particule va déterminer
sa position, en choisissant au hasard entre
l'état A et l'état B.
On observera alors que la particule se situe
soit en A, soit en B. Elle a donc désormais
une position bien définie, mais avant qu'on
l'ait observée il aurait été impossible
de prédire quelle position elle allait prendre.
C'est le fait de mesurer sa position, qui
va forcer la particule a choisir un des états
qui lui sont disponibles.
Bien qu'il soit impossible de prédire quelle
position va choisir la particule avant de
l'avoir observée, il est cependant possible
de connaître la probabilité pour qu'elle
choisisse la position A, ou la position B.
En effet, si l'un des deux états A et B se
trouve prédominant dans la superposition
de départ, alors il est plus probable que
ce soit cet état en particulier que la particule
va choisir.
Par exemple, si la superposition faisait intervenir
en grande proportion l'état A, et en proportions
plus faible l'état B, alors il y aurait plus
de chances pour que la particule choisisse
la position A, plutôt que la position B.
Enfin, dans notre cas, la superposition ne
faisait intervenir que les états A et B.
Ainsi il était impossible que la particule
choisisse autre chose que la position A ou
la position B.
Cependant dans la nature, les particules se
trouvent le plus souvent dans des états superposés
qui font intervenir toutes les positions de
l'espace, dans des proportions qui peuvent
varier.
Au moment d'observer ces particules, il est
très probable qu'elles choisissent une position
qui intervient beaucoup, plutôt qu'une position
qui intervient peu.
Cette description permet donc de tracer une
sorte de courbe, une onde, qui correspondrait
à la probabilité d'observer la particule
à chaque position.
Le fait que les particules puissent ainsi
être décrites par des ondes de probabilité
avant qu'on les observe, est à la base de
nombreux phénomènes quantiques très étranges,
c'est ce que l'on appelle la dualité onde-corpuscule.